when we were growing up dude we were not
allowed to have
feelings oh oh I I I can sense that let
let me tell you okay you ready for this
yeah okay I grew up in a
generation where you when something
happened to you you fell down you got
busted in the face you fell off your
skateboard you whatever happened your
dad was like you'll be all right that
was it you'll be all right and you'll be
all right was code for don't be a [__]
yeah and you knew it didn't look good if
your dad was like we should get you to
the
doctor because outside of that it was it
was a complete you'll be all right I
grew up in a you'll be all right nobody
that is not rub some dirt in it kind of
generation it was just like you'll be
all right why you [__] crying for
you'll be all right yeah you're GNA be
all right yeah and so that was the right
we we were't allowed to have feelings
yeah you guys it was encouraged yeah
well the uh sensitive is in being being
being or feeling the feelings is is is
kind of trending right now yeah listen I
actually think it's okay to have
feelings and I think it's that's a I
think we need to again I think we need
to marry the two we don't need to be the
in the UB right generation correct but
we also don't need to be this is how I
feel all the time nobody gives a [__] I
will also say we can't be in the you'll
be all right generation because my
generation is not strong enough for that
nor is the generation under me strong
enough for that I don't mean that as a
dig on anybody I just mean that as
straight fat yeah it's probably true
that's just two different generations of
people you know what I'm saying so I
yeah no no my my generation and a
generation under for sure the generation
under couldn't handle no if I could tell
you how many times in my life growing up
I heard you'll be all right you'll be
all right stop crying you're gonna be
all right yeah it was just like you you
got to the point where you're like yeah
dude I guess I guess even if I'm not all
right I'm gonna be all right yeah you
know yeah you used to tell me that too
because it wasn't like right away you'll
be all right it was hey you okay like
you good and I'll say yeah this hurts
and whatnot and you would go okay and
then you would let me feel it for a sec
and you'd go you'll be all right like
you you I was still involved but it was
still more like I tried to marry the two
and I think you did a great job at it oh
thanks man yeah because it it taught me
honestly like obviously if something
happens traumatic take the day take a
two days be sad feel all the feelings
but after two days max you got to get
back up that's where we got to get back
up and we got to get back into the world
and we got to keep pushing forward and
and take the punch and move on you know
that is 100% where I'm at is and
marrying the two you need a day maybe
two take to to get your [__] together
and to feel your feels but after two
nobody gives a [__] yep time to get up a
and I am a firm believer look and I I
say this it where I am now it's easy for
me to say this right and I don't mean
where I am career-wise or where I am now
mentally it's easy for me to see this
but I truly believe outside of some
really drastic cases yeah it's up to you
it's up to you how you want to feel
nobody can when I hear somebody said he
made me mad nah nobody makes you
anything that's your choice yeah your
reaction to whatever they your chice he
made me sad she made me sad no no no you
that's your that's your decision right
and if you're sad how long you want to
be sad how long you want that thing that
happened three days ago because you know
what in my brain I have really I saw
this
[__] I forget what podcast I was
listening to where I heard somebody said
you know they there was a pub in Ireland
that had the sign a sign that said free
beer
tomorrow but the sign was always up
because it was always tomorrow and when
you came in it was today but the free
beer is tomorrow but when you came in no
the free beer is
tomorrow wait that hold on they never
took the sign down that because it never
was tomorrow dude it's always today whoa
and well that just blew my [__] head
up can I tell you something that's crazy
when I heard that and I know it was such
a crazy weird anote anecdote or whatever
I was like I am through worrying about
tomorrow because it's never tomorrow
it's always today and yesterday might as
well have not
existed it's that you know yeah so why
am I gonna let something three days ago
that in in all like whatever yeah never
happened yeah it or it happened but who
it's in the fu yeah today yeah so am I
going to let the fu ruin my today and
I've I really that mind shift it took a
lot of mushrooms that mind shift
changed remember what I tell you on the
ride over here today you said your
energy and not just like not physical
not physical but like mental and like
your life energy is at a 10 [__] at a
straight up 10 we love that at a
straight up 10 that's dope I I yo I was
in LA last night I wanted to tell you
this went to the comy store by the way I
did Jeremiah Watkins his stand up on the
spot oh where you went up and stand
there with him and you guys just kind of
yeah re riff the audience screams things
out of us and we I did a spot but man I
was at the [__] comedy store and I
saw for uh Sebastian went up before me
what's his Miss gal yeah yeah yeah what
a and I saw last night at the store
Sebastian Nate barazi great and AR
shafir okay not to mention like Steph
Tov who we did her y dude she makes me
laugh so hard she's so funny I watch
Kevin nean do stand up on the spot
genius but I was
so last night when I go down to the com
store and these other
places it makes me so grateful and I
know how lucky I am to be in this
community of comics Nate Ari and
Sebastian couldn't be more
different yeah Seb if you just if it was
just Sebastian and Nate like dude
Sebastian and Ari like they're all like
but I was watching Sebastian because he
went up before
me
and he's a [__] Master
Craftsman and so is Nate and by the way
and so is Ari and I was just like how
[__] lucky am I to be in this
community how [__] dope is that yeah
how am I going to let and I listed off a
couple things in my head am I going to
let these things bother me this is my
job these are the people I get to hang
out with how [__] lucky and you know
what like I will tell you something last
five years ago if I had watched
Sebastian I would have gotten my head
about a couple things first of all I'd
have been like I can't follow this guy
what am I doing I can't [__] go up by
I would have been you know me doing I'd
have been [__] yeah yeah and it would
have also
eventually become a comparison thing
like how well how come he gets to how
come he right all I could think of when
I watched him was how lucky am I to be
here it's a great it's a crazy mind
shift it's crazy it it's it your mind
has G well I think it's also cuz I mean
look you've always liked yourself like
everybody always like obviously you like
yourself but this this last year or so
is when you've even said it you've truly
come to really like who you are as a
person and and come to terms with like
this is who I am and I and I love that
for myself it's it's such a crazy turn
going from going from self-hatred and
self- sabotage of am I good enough am I
going to be able to compete with this
should I still be doing this to a
complete three 180 Dee turn of this is
super dope job I'm super blessed and
guess what I'm here cuz I'm good at what
the [__] I do yeah like the fact
obviously like you've been doing not
struggling but going back and forth with
your brain for a couple years probably
since Co I would really say that's
because we live together again so I
started to be able to observe you that
sounds weird well I will say
preco I and when you say you've always
liked yourself not true
pre-co y I did and I didn't know this
until I had some time to sit with
myself he and I didn't know this until I
got to Nashville and could really get
into it I did not like myself there was
no parts about yourself that you liked I
the loud voice in my head that called
myself a piece of [__] took over it was
loud it was loud you're you're the why
aren't you better these people don't
respect
you uh how come all these people are
more successful than you your material
is blah it's easy I anything I could
think of you can't push anything over
the [__] Finish Line um yo dude this
the bad self talk was beating me down it
really was yeah and and in those
situations because even preo like your
accolades and your and if you look at
like your credits like your credits even
pre-co were outstanding they were so
good but it's really hard sometimes and
I understand it because that that voice
is loud has been loud for me for the
last year it's getting better at the
start of this year but it's still a
pretty apparent and loud voice yeah but
it's hard to
see it's hard to see what you have and
what you've done because of that voice
and it's almost prohibiting you from
from seeing all the things you've
already accomplished instead of or or
like what you could accomplish
potentially in the future and it's
making you focus just on the bad things
in that moment in that part of time and
it's it's it's hard to it's hard to push
through it's hard to get through for
sure it is it's helped me to journal and
write things
down I started so I would start
journaling not not so much of a diary I
would say Journal it was more like a and
then about five months ago I was like yo
because I had had like
a and instead I just I wrote down in the
journal I was like just write
down what you have in the first word I
wrote down was family and the second
word was health and then love and then I
wrote like five other words of things
that I have I have freedom I have Choice
yep I have some money yep and those
weren't even material things no and the
money was the last thing I thought of I
wrote career and I just went through
each one of them after I wrote them all
down there was like nine of them and
these are the things that I value in my
life M and I I would think of the first
word family well [__] yeah dude I got a
great family check Health I've had
battles but yo dude right now for my and
53 I'm in some of the best shape in my
life my brain is sharp [__] check
love in abundance [__] check and I
went down all these things career chaa
check peace freedom Choice check check
check and I looked at this page and I
was like like oh I live in
abundance this is the checklist that
most people would want to have in their
life in the first three family health
love check check [__]
check and it's shifted everything we're
like I will no longer think about what I
don't have yeah it's doing me no good
there are a lot of things I don't have
yo
[__] Dave girl is Dave girl but he
could write down [__] he doesn't have
right and people would be like you're
[__] Dave girl dude so yeah right
yeah the the the the the dude from
Lincoln Park Chester from the outside
looking in [__] check check check
check check check check you never know
what's going on in somebody's head right
yeah yep but I would I in for real dude
wrote those things down I wrote
everything down that I thought I that I
were as important to me and I [__]
checked them all off yeah and I do that
every day day that's good every day I
write down everything that that's
important to me that day and I'll tell
you the top three is always Family
Health Love sometimes health and love
switch spots but family is always right
up top and I always give that a [__]
[__]
because you know dude that this is what
I have yeah you know and so it's really
been a it's really important to focus on
what you have and what you don't for
sure um I I I did that a little bit the
other day um for those of you who saw my
post about my buddy Jackson and those
who reached out or had left a good
comment or left some love I appreciate
you guys more than you know it really
was it was just one of those days you
know where I just uh crowded my dreams
woke up thinking about him um but you
know I also want to say on that mental
health aspect of somebody might look
like they're super happy on the outside
but on you never know what's going on
inside and on that note again I will
also say yo after I posted that about
Jack I called all the boys I called Evan
I called Riley I called McKay I called
Bobby I called anybody I could think of
just to do a mental health check because
it's really important for you for
everybody to check on their people and I
just want to give that Shout again thank
you guys so much for the love and I Know
Jack as well felt it he was with me he's
still with me uh but he was with me all
day that day so I appreciate you guys
and on that note go check on your people
make sure they know what's going on make
sure they know that you're there for
them it's important love you let me ask
you a question dude okay do you find
yourself checking on other people more
more than you check on
yourself I find myself when I check on
other people is when I check in on
myself so I I find myself but also when
I when I check in on people of course
like they're checking in on me I think
subconsciously I'm calling people of
course to check in on them but also
because maybe I have something I want to
talk about or like I want to get checked
on but the last couple times it it
wasn't even that it was just more like
just wanted to make sure everybody was
good hadn't spoke to a couple people in
a while just want to make sure the
holidays were good and that everybody's
in good health and you know and that if
you needed to talk about something that
let's chat that was all it was it was
just you know a a welfare a wellness
check for for all the homies you know
and I think it's important for everybody
to do wellness check so check in on your
boys your girls uh your your people
everybody just just check it it's it's
important yeah I agree dude I agree and
I and I and and by the way man I think
that you are a really good friend
you're a really good friend uh and you
are there for your people in a very ride
or die way in a way that I do not
see a lot from
your um generation I shouldn't say that
I don't know enough people in your
generation yeah I mean for me look it
was like a throughout my life I've had
people enter I've had people leave I've
had best friends come in and then two
years later it's like I'm I'm invisible
so for me it's like when I find people
that I can trust and that I feel
comfortable around and that people that
I I like the vibe and I think they could
run with the energy and the mentality
that I have I do my best to make sure
that those people are okay I do my best
to make sure that everybody in my life
is is is set and is is good mentally
because you know just like we were
talking about tomorrow we don't got to
worry about tomorrow tomorrow's never
promised we don't know what the [__]
going to happen tomorrow all I know is
what's going on right now in this moment
and it's important for me to know that
in this moment my people are good and
that and that for me is like look when
you when you gain my trust and we get
and we have that love and that
connection I'm I'm there at the drop of
a [__] always have been always will
be but then the minute I feel like I'm
disrespected or that trust and that love
has been broken I draw a hard ass line
well you draw a hard line because you've
had a lot
of loss in relationships whether it's
friends or whatever yeah
it yeah and you've had a lot of what
would be considered betrayal yeah can I
can I tell you something that was one of
the most
heartbreaking because I know how much
you love and I know how much you love
your friends and you're a s dude you
know what you're a sensitive kid oh yeah
yeah you're a sensitive guy I love that
about you dude I love that about you I'm
not afraid of my emotions no you are
not did early grade school was probably
fourth grade what is it what year year
was it with those dudes started just not
hanging out with you fourth grade uh
around I think it was around fourth and
fifth yeah somewhere around there you oh
this was so
heartbreaking you because up until that
point and even after
dude your
positivity and your excitement about
life your mom and I used to talk about
that all the time like I wish I was
excited about life as Jacob wolf
yeah and your just straight up positive
energy was so
amazing and you loved your friends man
still do yeah oh yeah yeah and you came
home one day
dude and there was a couple of we're not
going to mention him by name but a
couple dudes that felt it felt real kind
of dirty how it went down even in fourth
grade I don't even remember how it went
down all I remember is that one day we
were friends and one day we weren't
that's how it went down yeah I don't
even know no nobody ever told you no one
said anything no there was just they
were all in a big group and friends and
then one day those six kids just stopped
it was
that they all stayed friends yes and
they must have had some sort of
conversation about something but you
came
home and
you there was a little ding out of that
light out of that
and you said to me because we were
walking home you know we used to walk
yeah yeah walk up the hill yeah and you
were like hey we were walking with house
school and you it was
fine
and this
is you said how come they don't like me
[Music]
anymore that was so hard dude that was
like because you I didn't have have any
idea what to say and he was like you
were like did I do something wrong or
how come they're not my friends it was
like and I didn't know what to say to
you because I didn't have anything to
say and I didn't have an answer and I
know you hadn't changed but I'll tell
you something dude it was it's hard
seeing a spark leave your kid there was
part of you that never came back that
day yeah but I think it was it was rough
and I had no answer yeah and I couldn't
say it was going to be all it was
they're going to like you or I couldn't
you're not going to it's a [__]
fourth grader there's no way to tell
what a fourth grader's thinking there's
no way I can't say hey you're gonna have
you're gonna find friends later you're
not gonna yeah I I didn't know what to
say it was at that at that young it's
hard to find the right words that one
I'll understand but two also that will
will give me hope there's no explaining
it these were your boys you were running
with everybody and then one day you were
just alone at recess yep I will say
though that that part that left me I
think eventually that part came back but
in a different form I think that part
came back to me as an I'm still I'm
still that guy I'm positive I love my
people and I love my friends and it's do
or die like it it's if I'm like yo we go
to I got to travel somewhere I need this
person I'll pay for your [__] but like I
need you to come with me I got people
who will go t toes down no matter where
across the globe if I'm if I if I need
it I think for me that part of me came
back to me as Still Still positive still
have that light still have that energy
because it's important but also to be
cautious about who you give that emotion
to yeah because some people will take it
for granted or some people will just
throw it away so it taught me I think a
little more to be cautious with my
emotions and cautious of because you
know I get attached to things pretty
easily people uh games uh drinks food
whatever and I think
what yeah I mean you went from people to
food and
weed but so you know I think it just I
think it just came back that part of me
came back but with a life lesson do you
know what I mean yeah so I I think I'm
not saying it was good that it happened
but I think it was important because it
helped me with how who I talked to and
made friends with along the way well
there's no doubt that yeah and also that
if I felt something from somebody to I
would rather save my heart and my
emotions and pull myself out of that
situation before I get my heartbroken
again do you know what I'm saying so I
think it came back with a valuable
lesson and I think it was I think it's
important I'm not saying it's important
to lose friends or learn heartbreak
but hard hard life lessons impossible to
go through life with no heartbreak true
it's it's yeah it's it's I think it's
important I don't wish it upon anybody
heartbreak is well dude can't can't
describe it but love everybody checking
on your people sorry that was awesome
thank you for that conversation I want
to
say
yeah hey
man oh yeah hey man hey
man